[Musik]
stimmungstest für präsident putin nach
wochenlangen protesten der opposition
erwartet russland gespannt das ergebnis
der regionalwahl abbruch der
geheimverhandlungen nach einem neuen
anschlag lässt der us präsident
gespräche mit den radikal islamischen
taliban platzen wie es weitergeht für
afghanistan ist oft ein neues haus für
das bauhaus nach 100 jahren zeigt ein
museum in der sauna ab heute schätze aus
architektur kunst und handwerk
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers schönen guten abend
hinein an diesem sonntag für einen
kurzen überblick über die
nachrichtenlage schön dass sie mit dabei
sind sports nachher mit rudi cerne hallo
guten abend in allen 85 regionen von
russland gab es heute kommunal und
regionalwahlen normalerweise keine so
große nachricht aber mittlerweile guckt
die welt sehr genau hin
denn die wahlen sind ein stimmungstest
für den russischen präsidenten und
insbesondere vor den stadtratswahlen in
moskau haben demonstranten gezeigt dass
sie nicht hinnehmen wollen
die kandidaten der opposition
ausgeschlossen werden
es gab wochen lang proteste zehntausende
auf den straßen mehr als 2000 von ihnen
wurden festgenommen
die menschen wenden sich gegen das
russische wahlsystem das oppositionelle
ignoriert oder an den rand drängt
christiansen berichtet vom gefängnis
direkt ins wahllokal ilja jaschin wäre
gerne wieder als kandidat bei den
kommunalwahlen in moskau angetreten
wegen angeblich ungültige unterschriften
aber wurde er nicht zugelassen
stattdessen wegen der anstiftung zu
massendemonstrationen 50 tage gefängnis
ob die proteste weitergehen wird davon
abhängen welches ergebnis wir heute
haben werden wenn die staatsmacht
massenhaft fälschungen vornimmt wird
dass die leute noch mehr ärgern
partystimmung vom wahllokal als wäre
alles in ordnung mit russischem disco
pop aus den 90ern und einem hasen die
erwartungen nach den protesten in moskau
geteilt
ich hoffe dass diese genossen aus der
stadt duma rausgekickt werden und sich
endlich etwas verändert welche proteste
die sind auch alle gekauft und
inszeniert der rentner meint die
wochenlangen massenproteste in moskau
weil viele oppositionskandidaten von den
wahlen ausgeschlossen wurden der start
schlug die friedlichen demos brutal
nieder
über 2700 festnahmen schnell prozesse
teils jahrelange gefängnisstrafen
die opposition will trotzdem versuchen
den einfluss der kreml partei einiges
russland einzudämmen
nach den wochenlangen protesten haben
oppositionspolitiker die wähler
aufgerufen taktisch zu wählen um die
kreml treuen kandidaten zu schlagen die
wahl wird so auch zu einem stimmungstest
für präsident putin
wer gab am morgen seine stimme in moskau
ab wichtig ist nicht die anzahl der
kandidaten sondern die qualität ihrer
arbeit und trotz der aufgeladenen
stimmung bis zum abend lag die
wahlbeteiligung in moskau nur bei unter
20 prozent
erste ergebnisse oder hochrechnungen
gibt es jetzt im moment noch nicht
weitere informationen natürlich bei
heute.de und dann nachher im
heute-journal geheimverhandlungen der
usa mit den taliban haben zumindest
vorläufig ein ende gefunden us präsident
donald trump hat ein geplantes treffen
mit den radikalen islamisten abgesagt
das hätte auf amerikanischem boden in
camp david stattfinden sollen
seine begründung die taliban hatten sich
zu einem schweren autobombenanschlag am
donnerstag in kabul bekannt bei dem
neben zahlreichen afghanen auch ein
us-soldat ums leben gekommen ist
wir fragen nach bei almaty wissen in
washington helmer dass wir jetzt
überhaupt von diesem geplanten treffen
erfahren haben ist das trump
rausgerutscht oder ist das teil einer
echten strategie wie es mit afghanistan
weitergehen soll
also die geheimverhandlungen die laufen
ja schon seit zehn monaten aber die camp
david idee die hatte trump offenbar erst
vor einer woche er sieht sich ja wie wir
ja an beispielen wie china und auch noch
korea sehen auch gerne selber als
friedensbringer oder dealmaker das war
wohl der gedanke hier jetzt in diesem
camp david treffen treffen die
amerikaner wollen eigentlich mehr als
5000 us soldaten baldmöglichst aus
afghanistan ab
nach einem richtigen friedensvertrag
sollen dann noch weitere 8000 soldaten
wahrscheinlich abgezogen werden dass die
details von denen aber zum beispiel der
afghanische präsident bis letzte woche
nichts wusste er ist jetzt empört weil
er sich und die afghanische regierung
übergangen fühlt und empört sind auch
manche hier im amerikanischen kongress
nicht nur demokraten auch republikaner
nämlich terroristen die
mitverantwortlich sind für den 11
september mit verantwortlich auch für
zehntausende von todesopfern in
afghanistan auf amerikanischen boden
einzuladen
darüber sind viele empört diese idee von
donald trump und republikanische
abgeordnete sagen niemals dürfen
terroranführer auf amerikanischen boden
kommen eine demokratische
präsidentschaftsbewerberin sagt dieser
präsident sieht außenpolitik als eine
art game show aber das sind ja
terroristen also die verhandlungen sind
jetzt erstmal geplatzt und wie es
weitergeht ist völlig offen
die hintergründe von hertie wissen aus
washington herzlichen dank neuer
rückschlag für den britischen
premierminister boris johnson aus
protest gegen seinen wechselkurs ist
arbeitsministerin embarrass
zurückgetreten
eine einflussreiche abgeordnete die
zuvor bereits innenministerin war roth
erklärte sie glaube nicht länger daran
dass das hauptziel der regierung ein
geregelter eu austritt sei zu ihrem
rücktritt habe auch der
fraktionsausschluss konservativer
abgeordneter beigetragen den sie
verurteilt als angriff auf den anstand
und die demokratie
der frühere grünen parteichef cem
özdemir will fraktionsvorsitzender
werden gemeinsam mit der abgeordneten
kirsten kappert gonther sie seien davon
überzeugt dass ein fairer wettbewerb der
fraktion gut tour nach innen und nach
außen schreiben beide in ihrer bewerbung
das duo fordert damit katrin göring
eckardt und anton hofreiter heraus die
die fraktion seit knapp sechs jahren
führen
bis heute prägt das bauhaus den stil in
architektur und design zum
einhundertsten geburtstag hat es jetzt
auch sein eigenes museum in dessau
dort wo das bauhaus seine blütezeit
hatte
es ist dieser prachtbau aus glas heute
eröffnet das museum soll die weltweite
erfolgsgeschichte des bauhaus erzählen
rund 49.000 stücke umfasst die sammlung
sie ist nach der in berlin die
zweitgrößte der welt mehr jetzt von
annegret oster nur eine halbe stunde
darf jeder rein am eröffnungstag so groß
ist der ansturm
die meinungen der menschen über die 100
meter lange glasfassade des
bauhaus-museums geteilt ich finde es ein
bisschen schade ist die transparenz die
versprochene von dem entwurf leider
nichts so hergestellt wurde bei dem
fertigen bau ich kann es noch nicht so
wirklich sagen weil von ihnen sollte
noch mal eine andere wirkung sei ja
gesagt und ihn sehr transparent wirkt in
ihrer eröffnungsrede betont die
bundeskanzlerin die bedeutung des
bauhauses als lebendigen leer und
lernort bis heute und auch 100 jahre
nach der gründung spüren wir heute
wieder die faszination des projektes
bauhaus bauhaus ideen bauhaus
architektur bauhaus kunst und design
beeinflussen bis heute wie wir bauen wie
wir wohnen und gestalten die dessauer
sammlung mit 49.000 exponaten ist sie
die weltweit zweitgrösste zum bauhaus
die ausstellung zeigt die designschule
als versuchs städte als offenen raum für
innovation
wir haben sehr viele schüler arbeiten
sehr viele skizzen notizen prototypen
also wenn jemanden interessiert wie die
schule wirklich funktioniert hat dann
ist er bei uns genau richtig
ein bisschen geduld sollte man
allerdings mitbringen die führungen
durch die ausstellung sind bis ende des
jahres komplett ausgebucht
so knappe sendung heute deswegen gleich
rüber zum sport und wieder ein erfolg
für ferrari heute show the player setzt
seinen höhenflug in der formel 1 fort
eine woche nach seinem sieg in spa
gewinnt der monegasse auch den großen
preis von italien in monza sebastian
vettel bleibt nach einem fahrfehler nur
der dreizehnter platz acht jahre haben
die ferrari fans auf einen sieg in monza
gewartet charles' claire hat sie erlöst
und sich in die herzen der tifosi
gefahren sinnbild sein kampf und den
sieg gegen lewis hamilton auf des
messers schneide
trotz dieses ausrutschers 17 runden vor
schluss behauptete er den sieg
wir haben zwar gewonnen aber ich habe
auch fehler gemacht glücklicherweise
keine position verloren aber trotzdem
fehler
sebastian vettels fehler mit größeren
folgen auf der jagd nach potters und
dran 3 dreht er sich raus behindert auf
dem weg zurück lernst du musst eine
zeitstrafe an der box absitzen
dreizehnter platz monster für ihn ein
fiasko ferrari indes bejubelt seinen
jungs dar
und der findet kaum worte die deutschen
tischtennis-herren gewinn zum achten mal
die team-europameisterschaft die
mannschaft um timo boll sieg im endspiel
von nord nach erneut starker leistung 13
0 gegen portugal ein hochkonzentrierter
dimitrij ovtcharov macht den anfang in
drei sätzen besiegt er portugals nummer
eins markus freitags mit sehenswerten
offensiv-aktionen applaus von timo boll
der wenig später trotz eines
zwischenzeitlichen durchhänger joao
monteiro mit 4 zu 1 besiegt patrick
franziska da vollenden matchball gegen
tiago apolonia im dritten satz eine
souveräne titelverteidigung deutschland
ist zum achten mal team europameister
christian hat noch was ich habe noch das
wetter rudi da guck mal schnell drauf im
osten starker regen teils mit gewittern
im westen meist trocken es wird nicht
wärmer als 11 bis 19 grad
heute journal natürlich mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 21.45 und morgen
freut sich hier barbara hahlweg auf 7
von uns allen im team 19 danke für das
interesse ich wünsche ihnen allen einen
sehr angenehmen sonntagabend